Banerjee is asking being a student is it
a good choice for me to risk all my
savings on my startup plan when I'm
totally unaware of the outcome yeah I
think I'd say is there a way you could
maybe take 25 years 70 savings or fifty
percent of your savings and test drive
your plan so obviously I don't know what
your plan is but it sounds like you
don't know what the outcome is the way
to find out what the outcomes likely to
be is to start you know again a great
quote from Martin Luther King one of my
arrows just changed the world and he
said when you're going to go to the top
of that John staircase and touch of the
stars you have to just take the first
step so for you I think why don't we say
how could help you and we talked about
it what is the minimum viable product
that you have to have to test drive your
idea and what how could you do it I
don't know for ten percent of your
savings or 22 whatever it takes but the
other thing I do and actually ever this
is really cool and changing the culture
in this company there's this thing and
it is some what I learn way back in
college called future future perfect
tense where if you've ever got a problem
or you're looking at risk if you imagine
you've overcome the risk and you're
living in the future and then you look
back so you use different tints so
instead of you know in 2017 I'm gonna
try to grow the business by and use
future today one hundred percent if you
say actually I'm sitting here on a blab
with Evan Carmichael we knock the ball
out the park what do we have to do to
achieve our huge success so if you
actually change the tenth of what you
use and ask you the question how you
know how did you achieve the outcome of
test driving the you had a viable
product for a market in your new your
emt new the customer needs what did you
have to do to make that success and then
say how much investment did I say you
know did it take your time and again in
the spirit of street fighters how can
you get people to do something for you
for nothing how can you get your friends
to mentor you how can you get
social bars how can you really kind of
really bootstrap stuff so it doesn't
always take big money to start
businesses and I think some of the best
business is back to have example a
really kind of ideas that have grounded
landed for customers and then once you
know what works then scale it up i think
i'm even more risk averse I mean for me
I hate spending money into line making
money I will invest my heart my energy
my hustle but I will not spend money
until I'm finding a way to make money
look at this YouTube channel I already
have a successful business while I was
stood my youtube channel I didn't invest
in anything i used my camera that i had
and borrowed a camera for other episodes
from a friend of mine i did to get it in
myself uh a dog i did all the research
myself and that was that led to one
video a week max because i think it's so
easy to spend money on the stuff right
like i could have bought the gear and I
could have hired an editor and I could
have had a white you know our green
screen and all of this stuff I got to
spend tons of money on this idea and
then I get into it like ah you know I
don't know if I'm feeling this YouTube
thing and then I'm stuck with a garage
full of gear right and that happens to a
lot of people you put a lot of money
into something you're not putting enough
time into it and suddenly you're out of
money because you spent everything on
gear and inventory so I'd much rather
spend the resources that I had with my
time to see if I'd love it to figure out
a way to make it work to justify that
this is an idea that is viable and then
as I start making money reinvest it back
into the growth so if i was a student I
would not be investing my life savings
into it I'd be trying to hustle my way
to figure out how I can make money by
investing my time I like heaven and and
if you if you're ever out of an answer
go and go and talk to your customers
potential customers potential
prospective customers and find out what
their needs up they'll they'll tell you
straight away with you gonna knock the
ball out the park or you get it's going
to walk into a wall and then you know if
you're going to walk into what what
would work for them to close that gap in
the market so I think you're right yes
exactly as Evan Evan
all that out